en tant qu'ennemi du rappel paternel Gannavaram
à coup sûr si une saison d'abeilles
se concentre sur la série pour toujours
Sacramento Ciavarella donner une merde
oh très - oui en devoir boum Veronica elle a
fait quoi aucune chance
plus polaire Royaume la la elle notre
soldat paternel quelques ha ha
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
contre l'expulsion des épisodes télévisés a
persuadé
le plan supérieur la disponibilité du réseau de soutien de robe non-amant
ok moi aussi
Morris Easton
Michelle capacités contre les
diffuseurs exposent vos voisins étaient
morts dr.  Jay Manuel Pardo III pour montrer au
président New York Washington n'est pas une
population carrée d'événement irrévérencieux d'
une épine dorsale, il s'est approximativement engagé
à combattre tous ces symposiums, nous
les frappons
[Musique]
cette merde est évitable
tant de pensées aujourd'hui bien contre le mal
l'amour contre la haine
[Musique]
qui vous rendra comme ça une seule
arme que vous devez combattre quand l'
amour
[Musique]
qui ne pense pas que vous pouvez toucher
Je vais descendre attraper et tuer
tous  donc je suppose qu'être une navette hautement
évitable
peut-être derrière j'aime les pouvoirs
parce que de toute façon c'est pour vous gagner
tous nos gars pendant que vous n'êtes pas
plus près d'identifier les deux que nous
recherchons vraiment, nous devons publier
ces photos que nous avons publiées  les photos
maintenant nous n'avons aucun contrôle si nous exagérons
notre main nous pouvons forcer ces gars à
réagir messieurs si je peux en
ce moment Austin travaille contre nous
c'est normal vous avez un meurtre aucun
rat n'aura ce problème dans cette ville
ce qu'il est difficile de faire du terrorisme tout le monde
veut parler regardez vous avez eu beaucoup de
gens qui en parlaient ils
parlent des mauvaises personnes
ça a publié les photos de nos gars asseyez vous
et écoutez faites moi confiance oui ne pas laisser
Boston travailler pour nous et vous dire que je
comprendre Boston mais je ne peux pas simplement claquer des
doigts cette décision
va jusqu'au procureur général
Je vais les appeler tout de suite c'est ma ville
Rick publie une [ __ ] d'image
[Musique]
environ un début en dix minutes doit
tourner  le jour du marathon tôt le
matin pour voir la mise en place pendant le
marathon et faire courir James dans
le marathon comme Billy Evans l'a fait pendant
tant d'années et avoir une marque là-bas
à cet endroit pour plus pour le
privilège de l'aide que nous avons obtenue  du
marathon et de l'Athletic
Association et leur partenariat était
incroyable, nous avons soutenu qu'il était réparti
tout au long de la course et que nous nous tenions en quelque sorte dans
les coulisses pour ainsi dire
et avons attendu nos moments où le  e DAA
nous permettrait de sortir et de faire notre
tournage, nous voulons être respectueux d'
être là, mais aussi essayer de reprendre une
partie de l'apparat sur Boylston et
ensuite vraiment nous avons fait l'essentiel de notre
travail sur un peu de plateau parce que nous voulons
être respectueux et le caractère inévitable de
ce que nous recréons est traumatisant
aujourd'hui, nous sommes ici, nous avons appelé le
décor de Boylston Street, c'est essentiellement une petite
maquette de deux parties principales où les deux
explosions se sont produites le jour où nous avons recréé
la ligne d'arrivée exacte  zone à partir de 2013
Eddy Jacobs a sa propre société de location
et nous mettons cela en place chaque année pour le
marathon la ligne d'arrivée est à moi les
gradins du pont la tribune les
tentes de minuteries que vous voyez sont toutes les
choses que nous fournissons pour le marathon
alors nous parlons  du BAA et avec lui,
ils ont en quelque sorte convenu de tout garder
hors de stockage pendant encore quelques mois afin que
nous puissions filmer ceci ici, notre ensemble mesure
environ mille pieds de long, nous avons deux
ensembles exactement à la même distance l'un de l'
autre  étaient sur Boylston Street,
donc les gens des effets visuels quand ils
font leurs longs plans auront les deux ensembles
exactement à l'échelle l'un de l'autre, vous pouvez
voir tout le vert sur le mur qui est
un écran vert afin que nous puissions remplacer numériquement
les ensembles que nous trouvons c'est plus
économique à mettre en numérique, alors
vous les construirez physiquement,
ils font un relevé laser de l'ensemble de la
bobine sur Boylston Street, puis
ils peuvent réellement le mettre quand ils ont
besoin de vous
et avec les zones vertes, nous pouvons
cartographier  les bâtiments aux magasins et en
fait recréer cet environnement à
peu près exactement et le marier à notre
asphalte et à notre type de
construction, nous avons adapté tous les
granits à la façon dont cela a été fait
vraiment dans les deux rues, tous ces
carrés de granit étaient  acheté, il
correspond exactement, nous pouvons voir les taches de gomme que
nous avons assorties aux boîtes aux lettres vieillies autour du
lampadaire, tout est exactement là où
toutes les plaques et les roues sont dans
la rue et le trottoir un  Tout est assorti à
Boylston Street, nous avons même eu un peintre, il a
peint les rayures blanches dans la rue
et elle a fait le tour d'un pistolet à calfeutrer, de
petites fissures dans la peinture blanche
donnent l'impression que c'est ici depuis longtemps,
c'est incroyable que nous ayons marché sur le plateau.
et comme wow, les
sports de marathon de Boylston Street ont été construits à 100%
précis, c'était un magasin en activité, il y avait des
employés là-bas et toutes les chaussures
étaient exposées sur des dépliants ou les publicités
sur les vêtements affichés et je suis sorti
du magasin littéralement senti comme si j'étais
sur Boylston Street, j'ai pris à gauche et
j'ai pensé que j'allais rentrer chez moi comme si
c'était incroyable ce qu'ils ont fait
[Musique]
et en tant que lundi de marathon, cela
vous apportera dès le début ici vérifier 1
2 3 4 vies il y a  quelque chose à propos de l'
esprit de la ville de Boston et de la
détermination des survivants et de l'
engagement des institutions de la
ville pour s'assurer que la ville dont la
ville était prise en charge Je me souviens d'avoir été
très conscient et très touché  ed par la façon dont la
ville s'est clairement rassemblée et s'est
ralliée pour capturer ces deux criminels,
mais aussi pour subvenir à ses besoins
après les attentats à la bombe, nous sommes venus à Boston pour
raconter une histoire qui honore ceux qui ont été
touchés et nous avons été humbles et très
reconnaissants pour le chemin  ils se sont ouverts à
nous et sont devenus des partenaires et ont veillé à ce que l'
histoire soit racontée de manière très authentique,
nous avons beaucoup de chance et de nombreux membres de
la communauté de Boston avec nous sur le plateau en tant que
consultants, c'est un sujet tellement sensible
à Boston, c'est un si petit
endroit  tout le monde sait que quelqu'un a été
directement affecté Pete se soucie s'il
veut raconter l'histoire de ces héros et
il s'est engagé à bien faire les choses, il l'a
eu en un instant, il suffit de trouver l'
humanité dans l'histoire et de la traiter
honnêtement
et c'est pourquoi de vraies personnes sont dans ce
film  même s'ils sont des figurants en
arrière-plan dans les tenues de Boston [ __ ], il
voulait que de vrais policiers les jouent mr.
Davis,
le New York Post rapporte qu'un
ressortissant saoudien de 20 ans a été inculpé pouvez-
vous confirmer même certains des endroits
comme la maison de Sean Colliers ou au
train Curtiss Somerville où Sean vivait, ils ont
fait quelques choses à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur,
ils avaient des murs roses je nous  devrait peindre
ceux-ci ne le pensez-vous pas et vous savez que je
veux exactement comme c'était l'autre
grand était nous l'appelions la
maison Henneberry a eu l'occasion de venir
chauffer l'ensemble de ma maison et c'est
parfait et Mark Wahlberg c'est  sa
ville, il se sentait profondément obligé de
s'assurer que le film traitait la ville
avec respect, la vérité compte dans une
situation comme celle-ci si nous voulions faire
un film qui impliquait tous ces gens dont
ils avaient besoin de savoir que nous
prêtions toute notre attention à  le fait qu'il soit
si soucieux de s'assurer que
tout est factuel et que c'est
formidable pour nous, nous avons passé tellement de temps avec
la communauté des survivants du
temps avec chacune des familles qui ont perdu
un être cher là-bas  e beaucoup de héros
ce jour-là, il y a beaucoup de héros dans les
jours qui suivent immédiatement en uniforme et
dehors Pete dépeint très bien le
contrôle 7716 opéré sur mon chemin du retour Jeff a
été très très utile, il est disponible pour
être un vrai consultant sur le film qu'ils ont fait
Je n'en fais pas beaucoup de fiction Je ne
veux pas voir beaucoup de choses dans le film
qui ne se sont pas produites Je pense que ce genre de
choses déprécie les vrais héros de l'
attentat qui sont les victimes Le
gentil vieil homme est entré et  nous a donné deux
incidents que nous essayons tous de
raconter leur histoire avec autant de
sensibilité et de respect parce que c'est
quelque chose que nous ne comprenons pas et ne
comprendrons jamais et je pense qu'ils ont été
incroyablement généreux et courageux de
partager cela avec nous  J'ai été tellement impressionné
par son engagement à bien faire les choses,
mais je l'ai signé. C'est l'une des
principales raisons pour lesquelles je voulais le faire juste dans
l'esprit de Boston et faire le bien par
les victimes et les gens qui sont
[Musique]
moitié  un million de personnes regardent  le
marathon de Boston d'un bébé aw à trois niveaux vise à
se comporter
nous avons plusieurs degrés ici nous
devons décider qui dirige cela et nous
devons décider rapidement il y a un
terrorisme assure le moment où nous étiquetons le
désespoir et ils changent pas mal je suppose
nous pinons Tommy vous pensez ouais ce gars
chapeau blanc c'est le gars le gros vendeur
mais aucune bonne photo n'est bonne nous dirigeons les
gens la ville vous les gars nous
sollicitons l'aide du public pour
identifier ces deux suspects nous
trouvons certains d'entre nous avant qu'ils ne le fassent
à quelqu'un d'autre tu regardes en ce
moment mais pourtant oui je sais que tu sais qui l'a
fait
pas de chasse à l'homme approfondie pour ce suspect
chaque centimètre carré de cette ville est
fouillé Kenton un lien de téléchargement je veux un
avocat
non j'ai raison
quand j'ai vu aujourd'hui bien contre  amants maléfiques
pour goûter
une façon de faire exactement l'
amour il n'y a aucun moyen qu'ils puissent vous gagner